yo thank you guys I appreciate it thanks
for being here I'm going to do a quick
survey of how many people know me and
don't know me based on that I will speed
up the process of what we're really here
to do which is straight up QA
and your [ __ ] mouth and so the mic is
in the middle of the aisle now you're
more than welcome to start getting up if
you've got a question and getting in
line because I'd like to start answering
questions as soon as possible but before
we get to that part
I'd like to get a sense of how many
people do know my back story because
then I'll set up the context for this QA
I'm also feeling a little bit awkward
I'm stunned that nobody's gotten in line
yet how many people how many people in
this audience actually really don't know
who I am or don't know my spiel plate
please raise your hand
all right this dude really didn't know
me so well he stood up I get it dude
[ __ ] okay so I'm gonna give a little
context not too much because first of
all I'm humbled by how many of you know
I am an entrepreneur I'm an immigrant I
was born in the former Soviet Union I
came to the US as a young guy three
years old my parents hustled and and
worked their faces off to give us a
middle-class life my dad eventually
owned a liquor store in in Clark New
Jersey and then Springfield Big Ups to
Jersey yes there's the seven of us let's
hold it down and I grew up real Lemonade
Stand baseball card kid real kind of
hustler kid [ __ ] student punted school
around fourth grade when I got my first
step on a test and and just decided I
was gonna be a businessman got involved
in my dad's liquor store business as a
14 year old hated it
by the time I was 17 I realized people
collected wine and that kind of brought
me into that ecosystem discovered the
internet when I was 18 at that point
spent 20 minutes in my entire life when
I was 18 years old on a computer ever so
clearly very different than the
youngsters in here realized that this
internet thing was something real
decided that I was going to launch a
very early ecommerce business and in
1996 I launched
one of the first e-commerce wine
businesses in America from 1998 to 2005
and in that five to seven year 2003-2005
that kind of range I grew my dad's
business from a three to a sixty five
million dollar a year wine ecommerce and
bricks and mortar store at that point
after actually building a business I
thought it was a opportunity for me to
talk about those kind of things
it first started ironically with me
believing that this new thing YouTube
was going to be big and so I started a
wine show on YouTube that popped and
created Wine Library TV anybody here
ever watched Wine Library TV appreciate
it thanks mom
and and that went extremely well that
led to me understanding that the
internet was changing the one that I
grew up with and decided that I wanted
to go all-in on that world and it was
actually South by Southwest 2008 a year
after Twitter pop that I kind of came
here really felt the energy felt like
the world was shifting felt the internet
was going into a very very mainstream
place and decided to focus on it couple
months later but while actually meeting
Blaine cook the original CTO of Twitter
here I invested in Twitter I wanted to
invest in Facebook and Tumblr in that
2008-2009 period that went extremely
well I wrote a book called crush it it's
good to see Stephanie land in the
audience she's my stuffy you know what
stand up stand up Steph this is my
ghostwriter that I reference all the
time let's hear it for Steph there'd be
no books without her that's not a good
enough clap
imagine dealing with me my absolute
partner in crime in that world and so um
actually we wrote jab jab jab right hook
on the floor at South by Southwest for
like six hours anyway so this has been a
very special place for me I stumbled
into a kind of a tradition that I ended
last year which was a secret wine party
I used to ship wine down here and then
pick a random bar and then tweet at and
we'd have like a Twitter storm it's but
it's a very special place I'm really
excited to be here again with all of you
guys what I'm here to do is do two QA
somewhere along my career after crusher
came out after my brother AJ and I
started vaynermedia which is a social
digital shop I started doing more and
more public speaking and what I realized
somewhere around 2012 13 14 was the QA
part of my talk was we're very honestly
selfishly I was able to separate myself
you know in general I don't do as you
can tell slides things of that nature so
that was good I had a speaking style I
would context the room this is gonna be
a very different talk then let's say if
this was fortune 500 executives you know
I was doing my thing but it was the Q&A
part where people realized that I was a
practitioner and I'm very proud to not
be a pundit or a social commentator or a
guru or a thought leader I'm proud to be
a practitioner I'm proud that I've now
built two businesses you know Wine
Library I built in five years from three
to sixty five vaynermedia I built from
three to a hundred million in four years
these are real businesses right and
these are not businesses of selling
people and how to make money this is not
gurus [ __ ] this is real [ __ ] business
and I take a lot of pride in that and
and in the Q&A sessions is when I've
been able to establish that so I got
selfish eighteen months ago a young man
by the name of D Rock came into my life
and we started making videos and we
started the askgaryvee show which has
been very very successful for me I
really enjoy it I've really reconnected
with a lot of you because I've been down
kind of head down for two or three years
building bainer in between Wine Library
TV in the askgaryvee show and so it's
been fun to kind of get back into the
world with you guys I'm enjoying the
format I decided to write a book about
it because very honestly the entire KPI
for this whole execution the last four
years is to allow me to come here talk
for five minutes seven minutes cradle
for those that don't know and really do
what we're about to do because I think
it's the biggest value prop you're more
than welcome to go to this website it's
called YouTube there's a fuckload of
videos that could show you exactly what
I could do here for the next hour but
what we can do with Q&A is actually get
into the details so with that I would
like to go into it so thank you guys for
coming
let's clap it up for each other you're
up my man all right tell everybody who
you are what you do Darth Gary goes to
ours
I know I know better calm stuff great so
the first time I ever heard the word
ever theater business context it was
from me okay and it really was just a
big thought process changed for me like
I'm not we're not just machines that I
go through the day-to-day were really
try to make something happen and have
these connections yes you know my
thought is when did that word in your
vocabulary and how did you start
systematically applying it to your
relationships I was systematically
applying it my whole life I mean I think
I'm one of the great salespeople I
really believe that IV go along with my
empathy I and I think it's completely
because of empathy right Gary like like
I know you we interact I know that we
met at that Salesforce conference like
that's when we started really talking
like like and why yes I'm caring but
like I understand that people if they
care about somebody else in return enjoy
those things like saying thank you for
everybody that was walking in right now
that's important like it's an important
process where I you know it's funny I
actually often think of am I using
empathy as a good thing or even as a bad
thing I recognize its power like
somebody acknowledging just saying a
hello like actually giving a [ __ ] is a
real thing and most importantly if you
understand what the other person is
thinking and you are a true salesperson
an operator and business person you can
reverse engineer it
to get what you need to get out of the
relationship if I understand what the
KPI is on the other side I can reverse
it I think the best salespeople in the
world actually know the game that's
being played
nobody's actually saying it in corporate
America 95% of the things that are
coming out of the mouth of my clients is
not what really is going on and so
empathy has allowed me to figure out
what they're really trying to do are
they trying to use my ability to see
where things are going or be current to
get headlines for them so they can get a
promotion in their organization you need
to know these things right you know and
you also use them to understand when
somebody's down you need to help right
so empathy I think is something I've
always deployed I vote you know I see to
my kids right my wife is empathetic and
I see both my kids already there in a
playground
they're four years old a kid Falls
scrapes their knee and they stop what
they're doing and they come over that
that's not instant you're not instilling
that that's a DNA trait you're
empathetic to somebody else and I think
that empathy and gratitude and
self-awareness and that's why in this
new book I went much more EQ than I have
historically because I'm ready to at
this point in my life to start opening
up on the things that I don't know how
to teach I know how to tactically tell
you to buy filters on snapchat right now
because they're under priced for you
know the awareness of what I think they
bring to the table and you can use them
to capture a little bit of brand equity
that will go away once everybody does it
in four to seven months I can tactically
tell you that I haven't figured out how
to teach you to be self-aware I haven't
even figured out how to teach you to be
empathetic but I want to bring the
conversation to entrepreneur and startup
land because it's real and if you're an
actual operator when you go from 20 to
640 employees in 48 months like I just
have it's only the EQ that allows that
culture to survive it's not it's not a
two-week vacation policy it's not all
this horseshit it's the human part and
nobody's talking about that enough that
looks like me right I don't look like
the person that's going to be the mother
Teresa warm feelings like right I don't
project that here when the lights are on
when I want to rip your faces off but
back home one-on-one I do that's how you
build organizations it matters matters
extremely matters internally and it
actually matters enormous see externally
because if you're empathetic to what why
the person doesn't want to buy your SAS
product if you actually understood if
you understood there was enough people
thinking the same thing you know just
the product
thanks Gary you should drop one of your
arse hello they work at Team Detroit as
a social strategist specializing in
YouTube yes a fan of the skvm Roger
thank you so much thank you yeah so um
you often say that marketers ruin
everything we do it comes to joining
social platforms and I think or anything
that has the consumers attention right
we've ruined earth we put billboards up
right like like any wherever we think
wherever we think there's eyes and ears
we will ruin that video games all of a
sudden had sprite like in it you know
like we ruin everything
we don't I we try to ruin ruin is the
slang term for being smart and
day-trading attention ruin means in my
world good things which is you know
everyone said Gary I want to be cool on
snapchat there's a business I'm like why
you're a business you want to sell [ __ ]
on snapchat right now if cool is a
byproduct of doing that then that's fine
but I use a tongue-in-cheek when I say
ruin it I think the people that best
ruin it are people that do things that
actually work
I think I'm great at ruining things
right when I say ruining I mean we take
a pure thing that is supposed to be
Twitter it's supposed to just be
communication it's gonna change the
world and I went there and sold the [ __ ]
load of wine and books and all sorts of
[ __ ] on it but I didn't do it in a way
that made people upset I did in a way
where I brought the biggest value I
ironically think that the best pure pure
and utter form of a marketer and a
salesperson is an amazing person you
know I think I'm an amazing salesman
because I really believe with my entire
heart and soul in everything I sell and
I know that 90% of the sales people in
this room don't write they make their
money because this SEO is still where
they're in right they make their money
in YouTube pre-roll because that is but
I know deep down in their heart they
know that they don't consume that that
they don't believe in that and that's
what puts me in a very good place and so
when I say Bruin I mean even as a
collective there's too many people doing
it the wrong way
and they're going to [ __ ] it up right as
a collective there's going to be 800,000
shitty you know snapchat filters that
come out over the next you know seven
months and that over time will make it
less cool for all of us as a normal
person right but the people that do it
best when it's always going to happen
not me not you not the collective not
the industry nobody's going to stop
advertising to happen in places where
people are I just want to show people
that there's a better way to do it and
it starts by not stealing people's time
you know it starts with that that's why
I don't like YouTube pre-rolls as much
that's why I don't like television
commercials that's why I'm like banner
[ __ ] ads in my iPhone like don't take
my time that's an asset to me and so
that's why the native movement or
anything that can remotely look like
that well to really answer your question
the people that can create the least
amount of friction by still promoting
their product win so I think product
placement in movies and television is
going to be a much bigger business over
the next 20-30 years because it's a good
way to integrate without stopping you
from watching what you want or stealing
your time thank you so much Big Ups to
the guy in the 8th row wearing a Jets
hats make me feel really good bro what's
up man hey this is Jonathan van from
Technium we invest in science
technologies coming out of university
but this is yes lessons from the
girlfriend okay
TV reporter outguess Raskin she wants to
know how the TV reporter how do you
where would you post to give value to
your audience they are a post on
Facebook you know the starter snapchat
for you like what else how do you gather
your needs on what where you see yous
going do it around the newsroom so local
news is being democratized and curated
in equal directions at the same time so
I think you know where they post is kind
of weirdly relevant do they understand
the context of the platform when they
post that's the key the biggest problem
isn't content it's that people don't
understand the context of the room
they're in
and thus the content never had a chance
because they lacked the self-awareness
they lacked the empathy for what's going
on there you know
you can't put a TV spot on snapchat and
think it's going to work it feels out of
place it's like the 57 year old dude in
a suit that comes to like a hipster
party in Brooklyn that has all 18 to 22
year olds like you're at a [ __ ] place
bro you
and so I think I think the answer to
your question is quite simple you know
news were always like widen and contract
right there's plenty of people that
curate you know I get my news from
nuzzle right which is like that's what
we're I get it or my stream when I'm
listening to people you know like I
found out about Matt Forte signing with
the Jets from the 7,000 people that
tweeted at me in the second that it
happened said what do you think like I
think it's awesome by the way and so so
I think for them in the cliche middle
America newsroom they're usually you
know I'm generalizing out of touch with
what their audience wants in those
mediums and they're doing TV in social
and I think that's a mistake and so I
would I would tell her for her own brand
first and foremost and then for the
organization she works for to start
really relying on context understand
what's really happening in there you got
it
Alan yeah sorta
but basically my question is on weed
startup weed yeah okay yes I heard
there is a company called cat Mehta a
backed by Y Combinator they're calling
it the uber for me everybody's calling
do everything the goober of everything
I'm the improv humans [ __ ] dr. Knepp is
your car all that okay but I live in
Houston okay for me good it doesn't work
right right now the other dish before
you started talking about Steve yeah
okay the rise of the rest and everyone
having an opportunity okay so what about
people who are like Sully or who want to
scoop okay after like drug dealers our
viewers of the purest form yeah no
seriously like it's like if somebody was
born into well right yeah they live in
Silicon Valley that's cool yeah okay
they need to get $150,000 license a year
if that's not don't get a twisted man
stop your hate real quick most people
that get money from Silicon Valley don't
come from [ __ ] Silicon Valley so stop
it right there
but keep going but I but I'm not letting
you just cliche it because that's
[ __ ]
she's not true good how does through
like me what did alliances study
cannabis what the movie [ __ ] Denver
[ __ ] [ __ ] Houston because that's the
current law
why do I hate Texas with all my heart
because I yeah stay I'll tell you
exactly right to your face
I hate Texas I listen I hate Houston
more than you [ __ ] hate the system
right now because I built a wine
business where I shipped wine and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] a sad state to expects
money the politicians had blocked only
one store from shipping the Texas me
because I was at the top of the heap I
was doing four million in sales here
saving all Texas people money because I
was creating competition and the
wholesalers three of them paid your
[ __ ] [ __ ] ask Houston politicians
to block me from shipping here and one
day I got a letter and said you can't
ship here anymore so what am I supposed
to do
I can open a store in [ __ ] Texas and
throw down or I can adjust that's what
you have to do nobody gives a [ __ ] about
your feelings bro no no no for real like
like and the reason I'm coming at you
like this is I'm pumped for you you're a
kid like don't cry about here's the
biggest problem
[ __ ] entrepreneurs cry about the way
they want it to be instead of reacting
to the way it actually is so you need to
eliminate rich kids because I was born
with dick I live in the studio apartment
with eight family members on the size of
this stage and split toilet paper okay
so there's no excuse that some most
people that are born with wealth bro
they lose because they're soft so if
you're so angry put it to good energy
and go move to Denver or enjoy 19 to 20
to chill then move to dinner or wait for
the laws to change you can't cry about
how it is that's just never ever ever
ever the right move
I would argue that there was not enough
clapping for that part right there and I
think I'm at the collective and that the
collective energy of this room is
[ __ ] let's step it up [ __ ] that was
some real [ __ ] see that was some real
[ __ ] Steve and they're like good [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] real [ __ ] sorry
hey thank you darlin what's cookin my
name is Maria Patrick I work for Capital
One and I'm a career coach in seeker
what career strategy in social media
love it I am a fellow recovering
immigrant great um former Soviet Union
amazing and I have an utterly unoriginal
question for you no worries
probably about public speaking what is
you know no one recommendation could be
in a powerful effective input for public
speaker who makes a difference
100% of your energy and effort has to be
completely predicated on what brings
value to the audience most public
speakers come up here and you're going
to see at any 7% of the time at this
South by Southwest the people on stage
are doing press releases for their
company to the audience period and so
the reason I have a career is I come
here and the only thing that was tough
love for a kid that I want to win that
was I didn't you know I'm doing this
because I want to bring value it's about
bringing value way too many people speak
and it's a press release and so what's
worked for me is the reason I don't have
the same speech is this thing speech
doesn't work for that awesome kid from
Houston as it does for a 59 year old
exact CCO
right of like an agency I have to know
the room I have to reverse the room and
then I have to basically deploy the
current state of things for that room
and that's what I think people have to
do I blown away by how speaker how
selfish speakers are blown away like
like I I'm stunningly disrespectful to a
lot of the people that you guys compared
me to because they're up there slinging
their [ __ ] and promoting themselves and
don't give a [ __ ] about you
hey hey um I want to ask you about the
summer you asked what's that weed yes
I'm not even sure if I've met another
human being that's willing to work at
the level I'm at so no and you can never
expect your employees to work at the
level of the founder because it's your
company and it's not theirs and to
expect this is one of my biggest beefs
with a lot of my founder friends they're
like oh they're not working as hard as
me I'm like you own 94 percent of the
company you're what the [ __ ] the
matter with you like I never expect that
keep going yes and since it doesn't they
don't exist
easy I am worried about surrounding
myself with the following first and
foremost good human beings that
understand that emotional intelligence
Trump's IQ in my building every day that
week I can teach you the algorithm of
the Facebook feed at the current
environment I can teach you
why listening and big data can help you
on Twitter I can teach you that you know
hashtag culture with an Instagram that
makes it work I can teach you to pay
attention today to musically an anchor
and peach and after school I can teach
you that I can't teach you to not be a
douche bag
you know and so first and foremost it's
EQ second of all I one by one one by a
Ben Ben Ruby Emily McDonough I want Dan
Grossman I one by one these people and
try to get to know them and I've spent
numerous minutes with these three hours
to fundamentally understand what makes
them tick what do they want
dan wants to be a big-time DJ great so
then I will introduce him to I don't
know Avicii and so like you know
what what I do all the time is try to
understand what matters to them and it
evolves when Dan first started working
for me he wasn't married right so
different things mattered I'm mentally
prepared to reverse engineer anybody
that ever works for me and understand
what makes them tick I hate when people
like Millennials there's no [ __ ]
millenials
there's no millenials there's Rick
there's car loves there's drill that
like there's people and I'm Millennials
that want to work their [ __ ] faces
off just to make another 100 bucks
because they love that [ __ ] money
right and I'm Millennials who want to
make you know the money's fine but
they'll live in a studio with 40 people
just so they can go to Coachella and
drink $19 green juice right so and
here's the best part I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't care how you want to live I
definitely don't want people to live the
way I do because it's super intense and
it's not normal no no no listen I mean
like the things that I can't control I
don't worry about if somebody gets
scared and quits vaynermedia then they
weren't able to see past the surface
level of the the stat right so I don't
I'm never scared I know what my intent
is I know my skill set is and so I'm
attracting the people that I want to
attract right and so the people that are
leaving and they've all been here for
two three four years they know we have a
pretty amazing track record of who's
still here and who's not and that's
building confidence and that's building
scale and then because I can't be
everywhere you know when somebody's
crying in the girls bathroom because
this place sucks
because their middle manager isn't doing
the right thing well then Emily hears
that she can interact with that and say
you should go talk to Gary and like I'm
the head of HR like you know like and so
I would say that um that energy thing I
you know I'm sure some people have been
scared but I'm a little bit I'm a little
bit I'm Way more energetic on stage and
when I'm on then when I'm operating on
it when you talk to people that have
worked movie for three or four years
they say that I'm overly patient nobody
thinks that about me you don't think
that about me if you don't know me right
like I'm a big time listener nobody
believes that
I just caught Steph's fat face my ghost
right cuz she's always been fun for me
to watch because she knows how my
persona is but she knows how we interact
she knows what kind of client I am in a
world where she's got plenty of other
people she go straights for and I have a
funny feeling I'm at the top of her list
of likability even though if we named
them all it would seem like oh no he
must be tough or too intense or this and
the other thing so I don't worry about
things I don't control I don't expect
anybody to be anything other than
themselves and then I think I work for
them and I need to put them in the best
position to succeed all three of the
people I just mentioned are in very
different positions than they were
twelve months ago and all right now
thank God
it's probably why I'm saying it or in
probably the best spots they've been at
Vayner since they've been under making
the biggest impact and having the best
time and we've been through our trials
and tribulations right there's been the
dinner when Dan decided okay he's not a
douchebag he's a good guy right like
that that's real that's how you're
welcome and this is why I want to build
a massive business because I want to
teach the world that you can build a
billion-dollar Empire on good like
there's no reason this this unfortunate
narrative that affected a lot of my
friends of Steve Jobs like it became the
move to be a dick because you're going
to get the best work out of people I'll
listen um you know I'm not Steve you
know on me I'll tell you right now I'm
40 so far here's what I got for you
people work way better when you deploy
honey than vinegar like you can get the
best work out of people I got much
better work out of people because
they're guilted to let me down versus
being scared of me get the [ __ ] out of
here Mary yes for being here thank you
concerning gotta get woody you from
Baton Rouge you know my bad chase bacon
mooch
and I'm loving daily being I want to
give out to let's go back to this bacon
Ric Rouge thing I think there's
something here I'm learning about big
shout outs if you vote for me let's hear
it up for D rock you Rockefeller let's
get fancy for private last night I'm an
operator also for par but I would love
to hear what you have to say when you
measure your personal growth and your
business grow how do you know with your
new good coming out or vaynermedia or
your phone that you're at growing and
you say I'm seeing or not from an
individual like growth perspective Oh
Airy the business is easy right like I'm
just talking my book people like win
stole the [ __ ] load more of these than
the last one so they're happy so like
that's easy we're winning the personal
part is a I'm in a funny spot with
personal growth man
like I uh I've I've been pretty happy
and pretty content with where I am
mentally for a very long time I I fully
believe that I was gifted to see the
positive and everything I'm Suffolk the
reason we have a good culture is i
suffocate under negativity I can't
breathe and so it you know it's just a
byproduct of my own thing I'm always
growing we're always growing I'm uh I'm
a better version of myself I can feel it
even on this tour I've never gotten
feedback like this like it's
unbelievable how many people the 92nd
Street Y talk that I gave which I'm
getting a lot of feedback from
everything you know everyone's like oh
you're really growing yeah I'm getting
older like it changes you want to talk
about different things I'm starting to
unveil unveil more of the stuff that
really makes me successful which is way
more the EQ stuff so but target to be
successful I don't think it has to I
think it could be a benefit you know I
think people found out about Zappos
through Tony Shay's you know early
social media stuff so you know I think
the mistake is a personal brand
look there's way more businesses that we
don't know the CEO of where they're
dominating and she's not out there
promoting there's some people that are
like me
then of course I get those questions but
it is not a cost of entry to be
successful in 2020 or 2030 to be out
there for your business to be successful
just go and build the best vaynermedia's
winning because we're the best social
digital agency in the land not because
of me
we're winning because all our business
if you look at my business right now 100
million revenue 60 or 70 of it is
because people went to other companies
and hired Vayner or told their friends
to hire Vayner because the work was good
I don't work on any account goose egg
robber parish double [ __ ] zero that's
how many accounts I work on so so I
don't think I have to be a threat retail
needs to worry about what's about to
happen over the next 20 or 30 years
which is every person in this room is
going to get product delivered to them
within an hour and in that world they
don't need Best Buy
they don't even need Amazon the products
you sell in Best Buy are going to sell
to consumers direct in their home on
one-hour delivery that's what they need
to worry about
cool thanks Brad hi I'm Katie Costello
super excited to be here
there's no lump part of that
relationship
to say
there's always a gold band awreeoh
meadowlands bedside I now live in
Chicago I work at a company called
creative circle or specialized staffing
agency in all the major markets for
digital creative
oh no way yep so my question for you is
can you name the Buffalo Bills offensive
line good keep going love it good but so
my question for you is I know that you
are really good at kind of predicting
the trends you're very successful that
you can kind of foresee what's gonna be
next
be careful Katie I know we interact a
lot and you've heard this for me I don't
think that I think I just move fast when
it's obvious I I think I'm willing to
[ __ ] work right like I think I'm
willing to stay up from 1 to 3 even
though I'm busy as [ __ ] and play with
musically when it's obviously in the top
25 of the free app store for months at a
time and I'm baffled that people in this
room don't know what it is
oh cool keep going with you know certain
things that I know okay you know you saw
this you kind of had an inkling like for
so long like this cute yes when was the
last time when kind of thought that
maybe had that intuition of something
and you were wrong or never on the macro
thesis but wrong in my execution or the
company that was going to pull it off
so thinking about South by I was
obsessed with Grindr
right uh
I was leaving that for you guys that was
for you I was convinced that what was
going on with Grindr between gay men was
going to happen between you know boys
and girls right convinced convinced and
so the way when I first decided that in
2010 the way I thought that was going to
happen was through people discovery it
was going to be more like let's meet
each other around similar interests but
what I really knew was [ __ ] was going to
go bound check awawa
right so I was chasing tinder for four
years right I invested in a company
called yo Bongo I invested in a company
called one I didn't invest in highlight
which popped here four years ago but I
wanted to but I didn't feel good because
it was too direct of a competitor of the
obongo but I was convinced it was going
to happen I'm so glad that tinder was
built internally and nobody could have
invested in it because I've been really
sad if I missed it it was really the one
thing I was scared of
I know smart refrigerators are going to
reorder your product I know virtual
reality is going to be at scale and is
the next internet for real like the next
true platform I know it's 20 years away
and everybody thinks it's tomorrow but
you know so I'm really good at consumer
behavior I just sometimes think things
are a little too like maybe I'm wrong
about how fast that's gonna happen I was
pretty wrong about Google glass that's a
good one I know Tommy I'm a [ __ ]
entrepreneur when you're an entrepreneur
you [ __ ] lose it's like UFC there's
no [ __ ] undefeated in entrepreneurship
it taught me it taught me how much I'd
love to get you know that scene in the
movie the cliche scene where the guy
gets punched in the mouth and he just
goes spits the blood and looks back at
the person like oh [ __ ] shit's about to
go down I'm as an entrepreneur that's
who I am
I don't even respect my losses I don't
even give them the time to teach me
anything I [ __ ] look them in the face
and go [ __ ] you and I keep going and I
mean that way too many of you dwell on
your losses
it's holding you back shit's over you
lost move the [ __ ] on
thanks guys we got it
energy still blows [ __ ] you guys
I wish different people were here just
telling the truth dunno man hey thanks
Jordan I'm from New York recovered
investigating newbs I learned about you
three days ago for the James Austin -
podcast yes I rip the [ __ ] out of that
right three times yes good job the notes
outside I want to ask you a question
because the amount of exposure you've
had yes it started well clearly not
enough to some man and and succeeded yes
would you really look for is the jockey
the guy the girl the girl or the guy the
jockey
I only bet on two things the space right
now for me eSports VR b2b because I
think b2c is way too far away direct to
consumer products that are fully
integrated uh those are things that I'm
always looking at social networks if
what's the next step chat or things that
Pinterest or things that nature so I've
got my thesis right where there are
things on SAS businesses that are in
boring industries where they suck at
marketing and I know that my help can
make it go through the roof so those
kind of I look for my thesis and then
when I VR sound I've been looking at it
I meet all the VR sound people and then
I look like she's [ __ ] a killer huh
so that's my process straight up the
onion but back to like if we're talking
like investment banking terms like we're
talking about our business
if you roll in and you're in a genre
that I don't fully understand but you
completely blow me away in my intuitive
radar as an operator I will often make a
bed an app because I'll learn alongside
that operator in a space that I don't
know as much about and I'll make that
strategic decision because my belief is
I'll learn this space if she or he loses
I'm still gonna have a relationship with
them I still believe they're a winner
into it I believe they get turned out to
be a loser that happens and then I don't
care but if they're a winner I want to
be there for the second and the third
all those idiots that didn't invest in
Twitter because they lost money with an
idea you know it was that was nuts right
like that wasn't he already won with
bloggers he was
really a winner you got a bet on the
jockey more than a horse in this game
you got brother okay I'm gonna like buzz
this really quick
so my question is what's your name bro
oh sorry yeah Diego nice to meet you
nice to meet you go thank you man
so one of my questions is I think that
messaging services are really under tap
especially in that developing countries
okay uh what have you seen that your
clients are like are they asking you how
can I get into like what saps
hundreds of millions of users how can I
get it in to Facebook's hell yeah send
your users yes they are and where are
they what's the strategy to get in there
it's a place where I've been very
careful with with my clients because I'm
very concerned that we because of what
happened with email and our texting
behavior real I mean I don't think a lot
of people here really want BMW to show
up in their messaging apps and I think
we are all way too confused by what
happened in China with WeChat and we
think it's a foregone conclusion we
don't factor in America enough that
china is still a communist country like
like we are you know coming from the
Soviet Union like there is a stunning
misunderstanding of what happens over
there
yes it's very capitalistic in a lot of
ways but there's no scenario in America
where zux gets to go to Barack you know
be kill snapchat cool like that doesn't
happen here this is real meritocracy and
so some of the behaviors and things that
go on in China are very unique to where
that's a much more real conversation got
it and so if I look at behavior now we
you know we all now have lived through
email being destroyed by marketing
marketers ruin everything I was happy I
had an email newsletter in 1996 that 91
percent open rates
I ruined email so like you know so I
think it's going to have to be very very
smart I do not think in between your my
conversations about the big football
match that a [ __ ] adidas ad should
show up and I think that's what
everybody's defaulting into because
99.9% of people are not clever and I
think we need to figure out how to make
it work
and I think it could but I think there's
dumb ideas right now of how it's going
to work and I think we really don't want
it this you got it
here we go hey Nina what the thing is
the most interesting platform right now
you mean like an app or overall platform
like got it
I think snapchat I think snapchats the
most interesting thing to watch right
now because we're living through the
moment of watching everybody go on it
that's always the best moment like
watching the masses watching like and
it's really fun to watch because it's so
different if you look at your mobile
phone right now and you look at
Instagram Facebook Twitter Pinterest the
UI and UX is the same it's a feed it's
the feed as we know it snapchats the
first new language with completely
different context plus it's forcing us
to be very creative in a different way
it's probably what it's forcing us to do
what I probably thought justin.tv was
going to do a new stream with live
streaming years ago it's created a whole
new language of creativity and more
importantly there's not a [ __ ] soul
under 21 in America that doesn't live on
the platform right and those 21 year
olds become 27 real quick and so it's
the only thing I've seen since Facebook
where I know the 19 year old is going to
be 26 and still on it and that's why I'm
so bullish on it you're welcome
yeah I'm all-in
yes you are Simon be careful Simon and
the sun in austin pissed on yourself
with four people in this room to see you
come here at different times this
morning
I cut the queue to meet one of them and
and then the other one said it's Karen
as we going in tonight what I say he
said you said great keynote before I
gave the talk and then you said thanks
for coming son yes I did I just blew my
[ __ ] watch thank you I just wanna
have a one-on-one conversation let's do
it up no you know the dude you see going
home no right Julia Roberts and is this
a romantic situation now okay because I
was excited excited okay that's what I
thought okay let's go yes I want to be
okay good let's do it and almost meet
you there at the end I was that he loves
her cuz she's just a girl
Jesus boy right and the good news is I
am just a girl
that lady okay no worries I'm following
believe it or not okay sorry share the
story I don't good me yes like I've been
through a lot of events yes a lot of
industries and Knightley not the other
part thank you
I'm gonna share a story please out of my
lives at least picture kill kill it's a
fishing village in Ireland right near
the border on the east coast picture I
think everybody should close your eyes
right now I'm gonna picture and it's
1878 yes and there's a potato famine
cake this guy has to take his family out
of Ireland so they go to the west coast
of England try farming here the mother
wouldn't father died the two boys who
laborers yes they're all labels - can
they catch us from from the boat to New
Zealand they get to New Zealand thank
you how old are the boys man I don't
know but I mean I really found matters
to me in the story okay go ahead good
just understood keep going and there's
some land and how did they steal it or
did was the government give it to them I
was doing kind of some sort of like big
opportunity of land grabs okay sorry I'm
just trying to help you make the story
[ __ ] better Simon
I'm trying to talk fast that's why I
think it's for my story quick no worries
I think that all right yeah I think
another story Simon I got a news alert
that ship sailed a long time ago fastest
over my man just own it go all right
yeah so they get some land my dad grows
up on that farm so his grandma I think
his grandad comes with her right
yes and his mom encouraged him to read
yes it reads for me to read he doesn't
want to get into the phone this is your
dad yeah for a 9:25 yes is fun okay and
he ends up through reading in 1955
getting a scholarship to Ohio State
okay hey just a PhD it goes back to New
Zealand these stats are sort of a
revolution and guidance counselor okay
he says to me when I'm 16 because I'm
like Dan I don't get in university I got
that my family is like this seven kids
and my parents is nine people including
me and there's like five PhDs it's been
like four or five academic careers I
don't want to go in this they did in
fact I just wanted to [ __ ] I love he
says listen keep your ticket I don't
care what you do I was just teach a
ticket
Yeah right this year keep some [ __ ]
ticket so I gave my ticket and did I say
game on right I said just shows in my
last year of high school I take that
drama creative writing and he's such as
your first time just shaman - yeah five
years later on 23 and
written for my sound girlfriend play
telling the story about Polynesian
integration into museum because there's
no [ __ ] modern stories for
Polynesians of New Zealand Kate excites
and there is this standing ovation from
this guy who is a top roping plan farm
grown-up guy and it just Ward's like
crazy as the oppressed moment in my life
Katrina and so it's good fast no worries
I'm with you man I am I'm with you I
swear
yeah yeah so in London I've gone to
television and then I've gone into
technology go into a Santa business okay
through my parents introductory yes guys
that studying meditation in prison got
out of prison met my mom said you
inspired me and amazing on this guy
Gerald Henry took that Texas yep it's
got Julian be such a [ __ ] amazing
gonna share a story about he's been who
came to America
sounds like my kind of guy yeah so he
says you know we should work together
I've become a meditation and then we
really sense business we launch it on
the lot on the New Zealand Stock
Exchange we have a million and salem's
it's a market cap of a hundred million
right cuz 2007 of course cuz all those
Wall Street and markets are full of [ __ ]
right and then it just got more Leslie
this to that sauce features go for by
pregnant Lee for a billion Mazel Tov
obviously silence and it killed me I was
making I made like a million a year at
one point I just think the girl no
because I was doing when you're saying I
did it was killing the same [ __ ]
thing 25 times a week yep stops I didn't
believe it was just killing me so I said
I gotta go and I met a guy at a Funeral
hey I baby another pseudonym and his his
his Robin or just dog that's right yep I
told y'all that not as a video telescope
we raise 50 politically a company will
list someone on the stock exchange over
two years 100 million valuation parents
I just kept telling it company like two
weeks ago sorry to hear that
yeah no it's fine because there's some
foolish shitness and there I am right
you know kidding how about is that
Gerald is a master storyteller the NASPA
business lady is selling something fake
already copy it because he's the crook I
understand the crow caws it go you need
to hook up with a kid that loves the
drug dealers sonic I listen I only only
because I want to be kinds of people
behind you I could do this forever
yeah thank you man I love you back let's
clap it up for this man get over here
I'm sure gotta go thanks again okay
thanks for getting yeah hi Kim top
Batman hi Gary
my name is Ricardo Ricardo I'm from Sao
Paulo Brazil pleasure safe you have a
lot of fans in Brazil thank you and I
love you I love you too
because you smell authenticity thank you
you know thank you so much man my fat
seven time years you are the first guy
that I saw you in the seven years in a
row let's stand up you know outside the
room to say hello everybody
oh that's all right I love it thank you
you know why you know why you love me
cuz I love you first I'm not joking by
the way the reason you love your parents
so much as they loved you first this is
a stunningly important thing you your
example to why you loved me was because
I loved you first and it wasn't a joke
it's actually something very important
to me my optimism is an absolute fuel to
my energy I am so bullish on people like
we've been around a long time now we've
had a lot of capabilities for that to
not be the case I know I'm getting a
little heady here but we are I'm so sad
that mainstream media took control over
270 eighty year period that we just came
out of and only talked about the point
zero zero zero zero one percent of us
that are shipped and it's our own fault
we love to rubberneck and that's why
they kept feeding us but I am
there is no brand in the world that is
more underrated than us I'm all about
team human and people get mad at me that
I'm like [ __ ] dogs and [ __ ] trees and
and I know it's not super popular but
I'm telling you right now I'll kill a
[ __ ] dog for a person any day of the
week I am a big fan of humans
don't tweet out I'll kill a dog out of
context out of context
don't be mean make the context make the
context go ahead my man
oh my question is but you are very
authentic e but the business world not
so many not so much
that's my opportunity let me let's make
the situation yeah we're you so if you
have to do away hfv yeah yeah yeah yeah
you have to go and work for all won't
happen won't happen I can't even write I
can't
you're better off saying may pretend you
turned into a [ __ ] dragon maybe some
people here or myself yes we're gonna
play yes bleep yeah yeah here's why here
looks like state let's let's start over
let's start over let's start over let's
start with why you don't want to leave
mine you like your car well
what what I'd advise you to give to some
people here so people here that can't
can't here's here's why here ready for
this that's right they they have college
debt they have this look here's my
advice my man and thank you for I really
enjoy this question and you have to go
tell your [ __ ] dad that you need to
fire the cancer no matter how much they
earn no matter how good they are if
there's a number-one earner the single
best driver of your business you need to
fire them because they're killing it
from the inside that's number one for
everybody else for everybody else look
I'm not some great philosopher this is
simple [ __ ] one at that
zit you're gonna die like I don't
understand here's what I don't
understand and this is a very good thank
you so much because it's actually the
next thing I'm going to want to talk
about after I'm done with this whole
thing I want to talk about complaining I
want to talk about complaining if you
were making your bed that you have to
sleep in it and you need to shut your
[ __ ] mouth right you are more than
welcome I've met hundreds of people that
have left their jobs making good money
when they had college debt 18%
compounded interest because they needed
their mental health to be happy and they
were willing to take a step back and in
the seven-year period
they won because happiness drives
everything you collectively are not
patient as enough
your lack of patience is killing you and
you're let your need of things is
killing you I don't even [ __ ] watch
I'm gonna [ __ ] whip need to be happy
one [ __ ] that bad go spend more time
with 80 and 9 year olds you know what
and I think three of you will do this is
why I'm giving this advice go do
something I did a long time ago when I
was charting my thing once you go do
some public service and go to a nursing
home and help I'm asking you to do this
by the way go spend 3 times 4 hours of
your life go there to be selfish for you
not because you're a nice person you're
helping I went because I was selfish I
wanted to go [ __ ] with people that lived
it I want to hear what the common themes
were and there's only happy people and
unhappy people
and the only thing was did they do it
what they wanted to do versus not I'm
the happiest because I'm doing exactly
what I want to do you will not hear me
publicly complain ever or privately that
I miss my kids that's my choice I'm
working hard too hard so I don't have
the audacity to complain about it you're
more than welcome to leave your dad's
company you're more than welcome to
leave coca-cola you've got other things
but you're caught up in the machine get
the [ __ ] out of the machine for a second
and think about when you're doing here
you're going to die you get one chance
you got so lucky you know the math
behind being a human being every person
in here [ __ ] won the lotto you won
you're a [ __ ] person not a ladybug
not a tire not this Mike this guy's you
suck they live so listen it's hard I
left my dad's business not so easy right
but you're in control of your life and
so there's only two conversations for
you you go and tell pops this guy Xavier
needs to get the [ __ ] out of here
I don't give a [ __ ] that he's [ __ ]
killing it nobody likes him he's cancer
and he's selfish and yes he's growing
our business but he's got to go or dad
Javier's got to go no son he's not he's
winning cool see it pops that's it
that's it that's it
all right rapid-fire time I promised
that my golf stage out time all right
hello good my name is a scanner I go by
I rock on on Twitter I was born racing
former Soviet Union I graduated from UC
Berkeley did research at MIT over the
past few months I've been getting I've
been getting flooded by emails from you
I didn't know what you did but I sure
want you to sell my part I'm gonna tell
you I'm gonna give you a story so I'm
running a company I got I got a good
favor that we're both gonna win why
don't you come after talk and I'll talk
to you one-on-one this way we can get a
couple more people well good
stop booing go I'm running a company
good bill
every third camera world for Sonia Macon
okay we're puttin 50 human years into
our SDK and now we're putting our
expertise into up 360 videos plus I just
another six physics video camera
complete a different approach okay we're
a rolled miniature economic greatly so
and the best part about it is we are
let's assume I think it's the greatest
thing of all time are you interested in
me investing are you interested me
helping you get to somebody you enjoy
that's impossible because I'm too busy
I'm alright yep so basically I get the
part let me do me do me a favor because
because I really want to be fair to the
collective I'll literally talk to you
one on what's better than this just hang
over there next
pressure coming my man Oh Gary
hello fan been a big fan for a while
awesome I am the founder of my own small
outdoor recreation business it's kind of
like the TOMS shoes of camping hammocks
I'm sure it's not the coober of time no
god a question I have for you is you're
so outgoing with your brand and you are
really the face of it um do you think
that's important for a startup that
someone who is marked out with your
brand no no thank you
I think that if you build the best
[ __ ] whatever you win oh you're
welcome
promise yeah my name is Ethan Simonson
habit stacker comm I build habits
through experiments living on the street
not eating those types of things
interesting I fully agree with you not
enough of us are hustling or complaining
too much
yeah we're not doing the [ __ ] work
yes so I also know you believe that
entrepreneurs are born not made
I believe big time all time great
entrepreneurs that build million dollar
companies have to have that DNA to go
there I believe everybody here can be
the best version of an entrepreneur but
that might be a two hundred thousand
dollar a year business because you
weren't gifted with LeBrons skills or
beyoncé's I think it is a skill yes keep
going now so my question for you is can
you hustle your way to be not no but you
can hustle your way instead of making an
eighty three thousand dollar a year
business to a three hundred thirty seven
thousand dollar a year business hard
work is the single variable that can
accentuate also there's a lot of people
in this room that were born with body
types that I would even look better for
the two years worth of work that I put
in or worse like we can't discount DNA
in entrepreneur land because it's not
convenient some of you aren't good
enough but you'd be unbelievable number
threes and sevens the number nineteen
guy the twenty number twenty seven girl
at Facebook made the right decision to
not start their company
got it like we are not deploying enough
self-awareness but hard work is the
variable to maximize your success thank
you I gotta go right I really do right
like there's no kind of like there's no
gangster like you have a lunch thing and
I can still do it there's just like ya
know they're really they're pretty
aggressive I love you real quick I want
to do some sort of weird contest um
right now I'm definitely not doing that
because I like to fight the system I
love you see ya thank you thank you guys
thanks for being here here